you know it what do you listen to what
do you think I listen to you I listen to
classic jazz in classical of course yes
you're so interesting I was I was a
concert level violinist until I was
until I was like 17 you still practice
yeah I mean the only expensive object
that I own other than my house is violin
oh really yeah is it a Stradivarius it
is not it is it is a it's not that's
alright no yes that's it yeah they're
the two that people may know or stradun
and like a coronary but those those ones
are like hundreds of thousands of
dollars this isn't the tens of thousands
of dollars
Stradivarius is hundreds of thousands oh
yeah I had a guy who we knew my family
knew he had a million-dollar
Stradivarius ya know so big about it was
the big deal well I mean aside from the
historic value of the thing they're not
making any more of them it does play
very differently I mean very differently
look I had a crappy violin for most of
my like really until the last two years
I had a violin that was handed down for
my grandfather that was worth maybe
1,300 bucks and it was a piece of crap I
mean it was a not a good violin if
you're good enough then you can tell the
difference between a really great violin
to play and one that is a piece of
garbage and I was good enough to do that
so that's yeah I mean I was I was a
classical guy I played I played violin
for years my dad was a growing up my dad
was a pianist look at what Jamie just
pulled up the most expensive violin in
the world sold for an estimated 16
million dollars yeah for a Stradivarius
I never lose value I mean really they
don't this is it this is it's a good
investment the person I know this guy
who wasn't offered a he's offered a
Strad it I think it was two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars maybe ten years
ago and he's like know that it's worth
like three million dollars to know what
is the deal like what if you had to
explain what's the difference between
the sound that this makes so I mean it
has to do with the acoustics of the
instrument in the wood quality there's
there's slight variations in the
construction of the instrument certain
parts of it are thicker or thinner and
it is also it's easier to play a better
violin so it almost covers for your
mistakes when you play a bad violin it
tends to scratch and screech more it's
why when you get in the upper register
with a violin you hit very high notes it
can either be very screechy or it can be
very beautiful some of that a lot of
most that's the player some of that's
the violin Jascha Heifetz is why the
instead of the greatest violinist to
ever live he had a Strad lady blunt
Stratovarius cost fifteen point nine
million dollar by these and then they
lend them out on loan to you know
world's great violinist so but there's a
better in the end it really is the the
quality of the player there's a famous
Jascha Heifetz story where he was
playing at Carnegie Hall and some lady
came up to him afterward and she said
you know your violin is just it sounds
so beautiful and he picked up the violin
puts it to his ear and he says honey I
don't hear it right now
so do you listen to any other kind of
music yeah I mean I like some classic
rock do you oh yeah I mean see rocking
out yeah I went to a Doobie Brothers
concert with my parents no yeah yeah
that's a band that was named after a
joint that is true that's accurate
I know did you feel like a little sinner
I was a rebel that day going to the
Doobie Brothers concert with the other
boomers so the